c'est une joie intense une onde de choc
un coup de tonnerre hier soir j'ai
félicité donald trump et j'ai lui a
proposé de travailler avec lui pour
notre pays
j'espère qu'il sera un bon président
pour tous les américains
je promets à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je serai le président de tous
les américains
un moment difficile dans les relations
entre l'europe et les nations unies dans
les états unis mais le président
américain est librement élu et mérite le
respect de l'institution européenne son
prix là aussi en face de lui la réalité
et c'est un homme d'affaires la réalité
il sait composer avec elle et il saura
donc s'adapter évoluer tirer les leçons
changé par la cellule diplomatique de
l'elysée avait pris depuis de longs mois
contact avec les équipes d'hillary
clinton mais pas vraiment avec celle de
donald trump
c'est une non pas vraiment une surprise
mais c'était une possibilité
j'ai ce sentiment lorsque je me suis
rendu à plusieurs reprises ces temps ci
aux états unis et françois hollande a
même eu des mots très durs à l'encontre
de donald trump confiant je cite que il
n'a jamais que le milliardaire américain
lui donnait je cite le hall coeur brisé
des maths très imprudent de la part du
chef de l'état d'avoir de telles
critiques pendant la campagne doit
coûter je crois qu'il n'a pas été le
seul d'abord un parc devons regarder en
face cette situation
et là encore prendre conscience des
inquiétudes qui sont provoquées par les
désordres du monde dans tous les peuples
y compris le peuple américain à gauche
on perçoit le danger
jean christophe cambadélis met en garde
sa famille politique
la gauche est prévenue continuons nos
enfantillages irresponsable et ça sera
marine le pen boire c'est le plus beau
coup de pied au cul fonds puisse donner
au monde des bobos des médias de la
politique des sondages
le peuple américain a parlé sachons nous
aussi en tirer maintenant toutes les
conséquences
félicitations au nouveau président des
états unis donald trump et au peuple
américain libre marine le pen qui veut
voir dans cette élection inattendue
un bon présage pour elle même il faudra
que la france et l'europe soit des
messagères de paix de concorde sur la
scène internationale pour éviter cette
montée des nationalismes dans laquelle
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite de manière générale et
par tous à des niveaux extrêmement
élevés en europe
après on l'a vu avec le bric site on le
verra je l'espère probablement demain
avec notre allié du fp aux élus à la
présidence autrichienne un mouvement des
peuples qui veulent être entendus contre
la mondialisation débridée contre les
traités de libre échange qui détruisent
l'économie et l'industrie